Speaker 1: We have a voicemail
number. That number is 2192. David P,
here is a question about 2024.
Speaker 3: Hey, David. My name is Steve.
I'm calling from San Diego, California. Please.
I just wanted to drop my $0.02 on who's better.
DeSantis or Trump. Right? Who's worse, I guess.
I think it's Trump. I think DeSantis obviously,
like you say, he probably could do
more damage policy wise just because
he's not so crazy. Yes. But but he I think
Trump would do more damage to our institution
long term and short term, just destroying
democracy. I just can't understand or
I can't fathom seeing Trump in office
without the possibility of him looking
forward to having to answer to the voters again.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I, I understand the point
that the caller is making, but I actually still
think that by virtue of being less cartoonishly
unable to get anything done in the net, DeSantis
would be worse than Trump. I still I still think
that. But I'm open to having my mind changed.
We've got a great bonus show for you today.
Sign up at join Pacman dot com. We'll talk about
the Twitter Elon Musk deal evaporating. We'll talk
about California starting to make its own insulin.
And we will talk about the euro dollar parody that
has been reached for the first time in 20 years.
And I have no plans to take advantage of it,
that's for sure. Sign up and join partners
Mint.com. We'll see you on the bonus track.